on the Nobel Prize to explode cast you
put enough rotation in the universe then
you have the problem that you can have
time loops and all kinds of things like
that George Smoot cosmic censorship is
you don't want to have time-travel
unless you have some way of I'm having
the time beliefs or sensors making sure
it doesn't the future doesn't destroy it
belfry in conversation with me Adam
Smith let's get here too heady teach me
well although every every week people to
see doctor who try Maureen yeah somehow
he only has a little paradox about a
really big one have a listen to the
podcast on that well price to talk
iTunes and on Android devices